>> ALLITERATIVE FAIR COP ON TEXT
, THAT'S A STATE OF PLAY
BETWEEN ONE OF THE WEALTHIEST
MAN ON THE PLANET AND THE MOST
FAMOUS TABLOID IN AMERICAN
HISTORY.
THE STORY TONIGHT FROM OUR WEST
COAST NEWSROOM THAT IS BUZZING.
>> WHEN THE WORLDS RICHEST MAN
SAYS HE WAS BLACK MAILED BY THE
WORLDS MOST FAMOUS TABLOID IT
TENDS TO GENERATE BUZZ AND NOW
THE FEDS ARE INVOLVED, THE FIRS
ON BLOGGING PLATFORM AND POSTED
DETAILS OF THE ALLEGED EXTORTIO
INCLUDING MESSAGES SENT TO HIM
FROM THE NATIONAL ENQUIRER, THE
PARENT COMPANY AND AMERICAN
MEDIA CEO DAVID THREATENING TO
RELEASE PHOTOS UNLESS HE AGREED
TO ONE CALL OFF HIS
INVESTIGATION ABOUT THE INQUIRE
GOT THE PRIVATE PICTURES AND
TEXT AND TWO, ISSUED A STATEMEN
SAYING THE INVESTIGATION THAT
UNCOVERED HIS AFFAIR WITH
SANCHEZ WAS NOT POLITICALLY
MOTIVATED.
BASE IS OF COURSE REFUSED
WRITING OF COURSE I DON'T WANT
PERSONAL PHOTOS PUBLISHED,  BUT
I ALSO WON'T PARTICIPATE IN
THEIR WELL-KNOWN PRACTICE OF
BLACKMAIL, POLITICAL FAVORS,
POLITICAL ATTACKS AND CORRUPTIO
I PREFER TO STAND UP AND SEE
WHAT CRAWLS OUT.
AMERICAN MEDIA HAS NOT RESPONDE
SAYING IT WASN'T BLACK MARINE
MAILING HIM AND THAT THE
MESSAGES WERE GOOD FAITH
NEGOTIATIONS TO RESOLVE THE
MATTER SAYING AMERICAN MEDIA
BELIEVES FERVENTLY THAT IT ACTE
LAWFULLY IN THE REPORTING OF TH
STORY OF.
THAT SAID, DAVID SAYS THE
COMPANY WILL CONDUCT ITS OWN
INVESTIGATION INTO WHAT, IF ANY
ACTION NEEDS TO BE TAKEN.
THE GOVERNMENT IS ALSO
CONVENIENT ON THE ACTION.
FEDERAL PROSECUTORS ARE LOOKING
INTO THE NATIONAL ENQUIRER IS
HANDLING OF THE EXTRAMARITAL
AFFAIR STORY.
AS PERHAPS THE INTIMATE PHOTOS
WERE RELEASED IN THE FIRST PLAC
OVER REPORTER FROM THE
WASHINGTON POST SAYS THAT HE HA
SPOKEN WITH HIS FLEET SECURITY
CONSULTANT.
>> GAVIN TOLD US THAT HE DOES
NOT BELIEVE THAT THE PHONE WAS
HACKED.
HE THINKS IT'S POSSIBLE THAT A
GOVERNMENT ENTITY MIGHT HAVE
GOTTEN A HOLD OF HIS TEXT
MESSAGES.
>> THOUGH EARLIER, HE SAID
PUBLICLY HE THOUGHT THE BROTHER
OF HIS MISTRESS PLAYED A ROLE I
LEAKING THOSE PRIVATE PHOTOS AN
TEXT.
WE SHALL SEE.
>> GREAT JOB.
OUR NEXT GUEST FINDS THE
INVASION OF PRIVACY COMPLAINTS
WARRANTED,  BUT ALSO
HYPOCRITICAL.
PETER SCHWEITZER HAS A NEW
DOCUMENTARY THAT EXAMINES HOW
THESE OPERATE IN STOLEN AND
MANIPULATED INFORMATION THAT IS
YOUR INFORMATION BY THE WAY.
PETER JOINS US NOW.
THE NATIONAL ENQUIRER SEEMS TO
BE IN THE WITHOUT THEY CAME
AFTER HIM, BUT IT'S KIND OF
IRONIC THAT HE IS CRYING FOUL
ABOUT STOLEN TEXT WHEN THESE
TECH COMPANIES CAN BE GUILTY IN
THE END OF MUCH WORSE.
>> THAT IS EXACTLY RIGHT, LAURA.
ABOUT A DECADE AGO, ERIC SCHMID
OF GOOGLE DECLARED THAT PRIVACY
WAS DEAD AND THE TECH TITANS
HAVE ESSENTIALLY BEEN SELLING
EVERYBODY'S INFORMATION AND
WHAT'S TROUBLING IS THEY DON'T
JUST USE THAT INFORMATION, OUR
INFORMATION TO SELL US
ADVERTISING AND THOSE SORTS OF
THINGS.
THEY ALSO USE IT AGAINST US.
SO TO ME IT'S QUITE IRONIC AND
SYMPATHIZE WITH JET BASES, BUT
FIND IT QUITE IRONIC THAT
THEY'RE RAISING PRIVACY CONCERN
WHEN THE HIGH-TECH INDUSTRY
PRIMARILY GOOGLE AND FACEBOOK,
BUT ALSO AMAZON PEDAL AND
SELLING OUR INFORMATION AND
INVADING OUR PRIVACY ON A
REGULAR BASIS.
>> AND OTHER POINT IS THE
EMPLOYEES ULTIMATELY WORK FOR
HIM AND FOUND THAT ONE BLOG POS
BASICALLY TRYING TO OUT THE
NATIONAL ENQUIRER AND ARE JUST
CELEBRATING HIM AS A NATIONAL
HERO.
LET'S WATCH.
>> THERE IS A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF
THAT MAKES US ALL PROUD TO WORK
FOR HIM.
>> THAT'S WHERE WE ARE.
I WANT TO TELL YOU ONE MORE
THING THAT THIS IS FUNNY.
THIS IS DYLAN BYERS OF NBC ALSO
SAYING THAT THIS ALL COULD BE
GOOD IN A WAY FOR HIM.
LET'S WATCH.
>> TO ME IT'S NOT SO MUCH WHAT
THE NATIONAL ENQUIRER HAVE ON
HIM THAT STRIVING THIS STORY,
WHAT I WONDER IS WHAT DOES HE
MAY BE HAVE ON THE NATIONAL
ENQUIRER.
WHAT DOES HE HAVE ABOUT THE TIE
TO TRUMP?
HE HAS EARNED HIS JOURNALISM
WINGS WITH THIS MOVE.
HE HAS PULLED OFF A MASTER
STROKE IN TERMS OF RECASTING HI
OWN IMAGE IN TERMS OF MAKING
HIMSELF LOOK LIKE A GOOD GUY
AGAIN.
>> THAT'S AN INTERESTING TERM.
A GOOD GUY, A HERO, HE'S A GUY
JUST LIKE YOU AND ME, SO IT'S
KIND OF AN IMAGE RECAST.
BUT THEN HE HAS ALREADY GOTTEN
AN IMMUNITY DEAL FROM MOELLER,
SO IT'S LIKE HE'S WORKING WITH
MOHLER ON SOME OF THIS KILLING
THE STORIES ABOUT TRUMP DEAL.
I DON'T KNOW WHERE ANY OF THESE
PEOPLE ARE GOING.
I DON'T GET IT.
>> IT'S INTERESTING, HE IS IN
THIS STORY KIND OF THE VICTIM,
SO THAT IS GOING TO HELP THEM,
BUT I THINK MOST PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO LOOK AT THESE TECH
TITANS, ULTIMATELY NOT VIEW THE
IN A SYMPATHETIC LIGHT.
IT'S NOT RIGHT AND MY BOOK
BECAUSE THEY MAKE A LOT OF MONEY
.
MORE POWER TO THEM.
THEY CREATE THESE GREAT PRODUCT
AND SERVICES, BUT IT'S BECAUSE
OF THE INVASION OF PRIVACY WITH
ALL OF THESE ONLINE COMPANIES
INCLUDING AMAZON, A BIG PART OF
THEIR REVENUE STREAM IS SELLING
INFORMATION ABOUT YOU.
THE USE THAT INFORMATION AGAINS
YOU.
SOME OF THEM AT GOOGLE AND
OTHERS TALK ABOUT THE FACT THAT
THEIR GOAL IS NOT JUST TO SELL
YOUR INFORMATION IT'S TO
ACTUALLY CHANGE AND MANIPULATE
YOUR VALUES AND YOUR VIEWS, SO
SYMPATHIZE WITH HIM IN THIS CASE
, BUT TO PAINT HIM AS SOME
KIND OF A VICTIM LIKE THE REST
OF US I THINK IS RIDICULOUS.
COULD YOU BEFORE WE GO AND TAKE
YOUR THOUGHTS ON HILLARY CLINTO
HILL I GUESS IS MAYBE THEY JUST
NEED A WOMAN TO GET THE JOB DON
OVER THERE RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT
.
SHE IS STILL DANGLING OUT THE
PROSPECT OF RUNNING.
IT LOOKED A LITTLE MORE LIKELY
TODAY THAT SHE WAS ACTUALLY
GOING TO THROW HER HAT IN THE
RING.
WITH EVERYTHING YOU EXPOSED
ABOUT HILLARY AND THE IMO SERVE
HOW GREAT WOULD THAT BE?
EGE I THINK IT WOULD BE AN
ENORMOUS GIFT TO PRESIDENT TRUMP
, BUT WHAT I'M BETTING ON
THE FORMER GOVERNOR OF VIRGINIA
WE'LL BE THE STOPPING FORCE FOR
THE CLINTON MACHINE.
HE RAISE A LOT OF MONEY FOR THE
WHEN BILL WAS PRESIDENTS, THEY
HELPED HIM GET ELECTED GOVERNOR
OF VIRGINIA SO THEY'RE GOING TO
TRY TO LIVE VICARIOUSLY THROUGH
TERRY McAULIFFE AND GO UP
AGAINST THE OBAMA MACHINE IN